nous voulons une campagne dit
calme ce qui ne l'empêchera pas d'être
dynamique offensive à tous ceux qui
veulent que ça change nous rappellerons
que le Parti communiste s'oppose
résolument depuis le premier jour à la
politique antipopulaire du pouvoir
pour un changement réel de politique le
parti communiste c'est le parti du
changement
votez communiste ce sera aussi à porter
son soutien à des hommes à des femmes
intègres compétents dévouées dans
l'expérience montre qu'il défendent en
toute circonstances les droits et les
revendications des travailleurs des
familles
votez communiste ce sera enfin approuvé
et soutenir les efforts patients et
inlassables du
parti pour que l'union des parties de
l'Union Populaire progresse encore se
consolide jusqu'à devenir irrévers
en bref nous allons appeler à voter
massivement au premier tour pour des
candidats communistes d'autant plus
qu'avec le mode de scrutin actuel il
faut donner beaucoup plus de voix aux
candidats communistes aux autres si l'on
veut qu'ils obtiennent une juste
représentation et soit en nombre
suffisant à l'Assemblée nationale pour
défendre les revendications populaires
et agir pour la mise en œuvre du
programme commun